this is what we've been waiting for the
final boss
there's the bra we have to get the bra
from the washing line but it is defended
by the next Metal Gear Metal Gear Sheela
she has broad powers we must rescue the
just don't ask questions we're gonna
rescue the bra Metal Gear style okay
just in case you're wondering we are
playing a new game which is just a metal
ps4 today called untitled goos game it's
been out for a while so I thought I'd
mess around with this and pretend it was
Metal Gear Solid
yeah first task finish our sandwich and
get in the garden we can do that with
the radio we just Scottish music for
some reason yeah come and check dude
black pipes you can have the radio just
come over here come over here come over
here come up here I lied
there you go haha we're bandits thanks
for the garden Simo yes let's get the
sprinkler going we're gonna Nick these
keys these keys are ours its way here
when he comes fast
give me the gate dammit dammit get round
him he doesn't know we're here we stuff
stealth give me the keys
haha stealth oh he's on to us he's on to
us
we gotta make this
that's faster with wings I gave up oh
okay
he wants to paddle instead okay take
this to our secret home base which is a
random square for a picnic everything we
pillage see it we'll put here this is
our pillaging square can't have a picnic
without a picnic basket yeah we got this
for the day keep us away oh 24 my picnic
god damn you man you dude I wanted a
picnic you know what I'm gonna Nick your
jam instead yeah we're jammin were
jammin were jammin with yummy think I
can hit this big-ass box all the way
there without being noticed this is
gonna take a while we can pinch his
break we've got this in the bag
break in the lake I've set up for this
no there's a hole in the fence which we
can fit this through watch this stuff
genius uh Shh
didn't think this one through did I no I
don't want to use the gate kid off my
rake get off my rake get off my rake I
do not next time oh I will
you up can we do now right here's the
thing we're gonna pretend to be working
on the farm some I'm a working goose
I put carrots in baskets I'm the best
work of this guy house
I deserve a pay rise my biggest trust
yeah
you trust me don't you yeah hey trust me
you trust me which means we can do this
now operation rake in Lake why do I keep
singing add the music we're almost there
we're almost there we got this
apparition rake in delay best in the
world new to-do item make the
groundskeeper hammer his thumb you got
it let's do this let's do this okay what
the hell is this
no geese allowed what's this racism come
from what you think you did this is what
I want to talk about look look at this
what's this this is racism this is
disgusting behavior
look at this I'm appalled I'm appalled I
am gonna mess you up
I really am okay what do you think is
gonna happen mate what do you think is
gonna happen
hey yeah that's what happens you see oh
we got a new level gather way this is
the end of Metal Gear Solid 1 sons of
goo C's gooses of Patriots right you get
that I'm going through here taking your
hammer ha ha I am for damnit all right
I'll be the trickster god you'd be Thor
I'll be I'll be low-key so this is your
gratitude boy well I don't want to see I
must get boys
goose goose let's all look rake rake in
the lake come off it love I just want
the that brush
it's the brush we'll have to do
something about that damn brush
not again go away with the brush one day
one day I'll mess you up hey I've got
you a walkie-talkie love just for you
I'm trying to be not the dumb brush
again that broom is the bane of my life
yeah oh you can grab it you can grab it
look give me the damn brush litoris ah
you're not messing anybody up anymore
are you
your reign of tyranny is over I found a
bottle can't help me I'm gonna brew my
goose hey little boy run while you can
noise let's just figure this out one
time you get in there yeah don't come
out a wreck you next time oh that was
actually something we have to do and
they've called the person in the shop oh
you know what we're doing we're hiding
and we're getting in this shop stuff
stuff ridin oh this is my shop now you
want to buy a CRT TV from 1980 come to
me I'm on TV
check me out I can sing do bees but life
let's we do the death match
[Music]
bop bop-bop-bop
better stop listen Oh Minnie a copyright
claims can run from me boy oh I'm still
gonna mess you up you're going down
hey who you can grab his shoelaces
let's to help us it up yeah people talk
I was gonna borrow your glasses sorry
about hitting your head on the dustbin
lid though is quality
[Music]
just suffer
every night I steal some glasses for the
boy there we go
ego mate is a freebie for you Mary
Chrysler you look gorgeous looking good
dude shoot yeah shoelaces good idea hmm
so the garage is now open so I'll put
the rubbish the trash the garbage in the
garage and then shut the gap I am
regretting this decision already damn it
let me out
what the hell of you what's this poster
about no case we will need to talk about
itself
this is not good enough it's not good
enough at all
I'm stealth you are now trapped metal
gear shopkeeper defeated I am this one
of death goose I need to remember that
Metal Gear Solid to complete operation
big shell what's next
Bruce a new level we've got Gardens
we've got washing line socks and a Brock
was that a bra operation bra begins we
must save the bra oh we smash back doors
in here make some room in the house Oh
spotted cricket spotted cricket anybody
around to play a spotted cricket
oh hello Jeff spotted cricket Jeff okay
Jeff you take that and I'll have your
newspaper aha does it sink or swim
what's all this about Jeff why have you
got a bright pink bomb Jeff may be blind
as well as stupid as you want
I mean fast humming Vaz sorry slip of
the tongue oh you stroke just throw it
next door I'm going for the Bell
Jeff what is T that's the worst thing
that can happen to a British person
it really is it's it's a shameful thing
where you draw a Sulha ah operation
escape Sheila who taking he jokes
[Music]
you had a pair of jokes not anymore hi
Jeff I stole some jokes look I'm an
aristocrat no let's hypothesis something
something intelligent words damn you
Jeff
next time Jeff come on
operation bra dick day yes we've got it
we're gonna play the secret code on the
chimes to get through this that unlocks
the special drawers Sheila hasn't got a
chance we've done it we have finished
the game Jeff we have done it we
finished everything little Jeff he's
actually a secret agent is it on our
side at all Jeff is one of the bad guys
Metal Gear Jeff we need to escape back
to the only way to win the game
Victor Billy dammit jeff you pervert
give me the back oh we did it we
completed the game we just need to put
some teeth on the bra and that's it
Metal Gear Solid goose edition complete
thank you very much for watching this
absolute rubbish I do hope you enjoyed
yourself
his is a swan goose duck thing with a
bra you're welcome I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
sorry
[Music]